we have an exclusive right now that
maybe by the time this comes out will
not be exclusive but in the moment it is
exclusive we have the next fight yes sir
and who do we have Korean zombie Korean
zombie in Singapore so I'm excited I'm
excited bro I'm excited Bro you've been
uh that's one of the guys in that song
before the fight
[Laughter]
we might might be a good idea I like
your mental offer yeah you gotta walk
out to that [__] get it you walk out
with him I mean I might cry I gotta
actually
okay so Korean zombie
this is
there's I think there are very few more
where there are very few fights in MMA
that are offering guaranteed
fireworks like this fight
insane yeah excitement people don't know
yet do you need to get up for a fight
like this do you need to
like is is this something you've looked
for for a year like I'm like how do you
get yourself in a position where like
you know what I really want this you've
been fighting for the belt non-stop for
the last how many years forever if I was
like well right but it is what it is bro
you know at the end of the day the whole
everybody asks me oh where where's your
mind at what is your what is your drive
what is your push and like bro yeah I'm
gonna go out there I'm gonna fight in
front of potentially millions of people
so I just want to get my ass kicked in
front of millions of people you know I
don't want to become a meme yeah I don't
want people to be harassing me so I damn
day this is another fight you know I've
been watching uh Korean forever since
he's we see you know he was like one of
those guys like like Aldo yeah you know
you know although I fought Jeremy you
know I mean crazy but Ricardo Lamas you
know adults Emporia so there's all these
guys that like these are the guys I used
to watch so this is the guys that yeah
if I ever had the shot to fight him if
they stood around and fight them and he
stood around you know he still want to
considered one of the best guys in the
world so it makes sense yeah no that's
going to be a crazy friend and his last
fight was Volk yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and Volk was pretty dominant yeah
yeah do you want another crack at vulk
oh 100 bro I was just I was telling Tim
bro like it sucks that we it just keep
happening but like if I was if if the
rose was reversed I get it bro you know
we're the best in the world I just want
to fight the best guy in the world yeah
also yeah I mean if you've seen a woman
to fight Vogue start giving me stop
giving me these freaking these
contenders you're not gonna give me
somebody else or something let's go make
fun fights you know let's let's make
another another belt you know most
talkative [__]
give me another Bell you know but then
I'm gonna be there you know I would love
to fight him he's one of the best guys
in the world yeah and being able to [__]
octagon with him again for however we
got to think you could have done
differently after the last one I mean it
just happened bro this is night bro
there's nothing I would change nothing
bro everything happened I I did a great
training camp but my mentor is great he
just went out there he did his thing bro
you kind of I I hate I hate when like I
remember having my breakout fight in New
Jersey actually against uh Cub Swanson
yeah and I hate when people was like oh
that doesn't look like the Cubs wants
you know they try to take away right
yeah even when they said oh I didn't
feel right like I went in there we all
get injuries we all have something so we
have personal [__] going on of course
yeah he just went out there he showed up
that night you know I mean I showed up
too but he just [__] did better I'm
not gonna stay away from him you know I
didn't do we freaking we figured it out
I'll get back I'll get back to there and
if we can fight again fight again it was
uh it was interesting your your Trilogy
because I feel like each of you made
adjustments like fight one to fight two
you made big adjustments yeah like first
two rounds easy your walk around it was
good I actually had you winning the
second fight yeah I know that was a
really close fight but I had you I had
you win the second fight because you
made those adjustments then three it
feels like he made those adjustments
yeah and I feel like it's ping pong with
you guys like I feel like next best in
the world bro when you're the best in
the world the only thing that separates
you is when I tell people everything
that Separates Me from someone who's not
in the UFC it's just I know how to put
things together a little bit or I know
how to mentally play that mental game
and that's why I tell everybody all the
upper comers they're like oh what did
you speak about blah I ain't got no
secret I was like look everybody in the
in the UFC know how to throw one two
know how to block a one two yeah except
for Ortega at the time
oh Joe
everybody know how to do everything it's
just who's gonna apply their game plan
first and be and be constant on it you
know and that's why I said like I'm no
different than anybody the only
difference between the top 15 Fighters
and the rest of UC is they know how to
put it together as a mind thing you know
and then you go up to the 10. five
minding and the champion is this a mind
game you cannot say anybody's like we
all know how to fight yeah then it is
who's putting it together one thing by
that you mean game plan you mean
preparation plan preparation and just
showing up you know I mean like most of
the time half of these guys beat
themselves before they even step in
knock out somewhere yeah how so they
just beat himself you know I mean like
the moment gets to him
the moment gets to him you know like
when I fall you can tell they're nervous
yeah or or or something's going on you
know I remember when I fought Dustin
Poirier the first fight my USC even you
know my first ever UFC event we was the
headline at the time was the FX card so
right before the Pay-Per-View we go
there early yeah I mean I I see people I
see Stephen Thompson was like the second
fighter tonight or third fight I forget
what fight it was but I was so empty I
remember watching this place like cool
yeah they showed across empty I was like
holy [__] this is like fighting in
Hawaii you know like there's nothing
I remember I had a famous boxer a famous
Hawaiian box in my corner his name was
Jesus salute okay yeah the Hawaiian
Punch they used to call him but uh the
original one yeah he was the whole
original Hawaiian plants so Brian got it
after him
look him up yeah so he said this man he
was like he'd been there so he's like
telling me Max when this lights go on uh
just stay calm stay calm stay calm and I
was thinking I got this don't worry no
worry [__] lights can win on I was
like 200 miles per hour bro the freaking
this is right before the main cartel
every seat was fielded
I remember being in there and just
thinking like uh uh just thinking when
Bruce was uh introducing me they're
saying my name like my knees is weak I
was like holy [__] I was like bro you
can't be fainting Max you're on [__]
TV you know I mean like I was like what
the hell so a moment got to me you know
I had a little bit and then I remember
fight week two I saw Georgie Pierre I
saw Anderson Silva I saw Jose Aldo
Frankie like who's who like all these
guys that wanted to and I remember being
back me in the back after I lost I lost
I did I had I looked good in the feet I
got took a nun and he like triangle arm
barred me and from the top which is
crazy like he triangled on by me from
the top so yeah and I was like what the
hell and I remember seeing the back and
thinking to myself like
[__] this yeah I was like why are you
acting like this why are you acting so
Starstruck around these guys like you're
a UFC fighter you belong here [__]
act like it so like for now like I don't
act I don't really ask too much people
for pictures or whatever because like in
my mind like I can do that when I'm done
you know when I when I when I can take
it in you know what I mean but right now
it's a game time like even the same with
all the like I have titles like
everybody's like oh why don't you have
your titles like put around the house
and blah blah this and that I was like I
said fighting that's why and they don't
understand it I was like what do you
mean I was like I'm stood fighting yeah
don't focus on what you did yeah yeah
what I want to do I still want to do
this you know like I'll bring out all
the belts and stuff when I retire and I
can celebrate them right now there's no
celebration it's so freaking grind all
the way through you know yeah do you
have a specific pre-fight ritual now to
keep you in the moment
not really I'm just sitting in the back
and I mean I get nervous bro if somebody
tells you I mean I'm sure do you get
nervous before going on stage when
you're doing a show or something yeah
but I think the bigger the event yeah
more anxiety for sure you know I mean
and that's how you're supposed to feel
it I think if you don't if you don't
feel anything yeah you're not human you
never do do the work yeah I was like bro
if you feel if you don't feel nothing I
tell them bro you didn't do enough work
you didn't know like I sacrificed so
much that's like I might get nervous
because I'm like [__] what if I let
people die my mind is like what if I let
this guy's down like I missed my son's
birthday I missed my wife's birthday
yeah yeah this can't be not I gotta go
out there and [__] give it my all and
then if I do end up on the bad side at
least I can look myself and look at my
love when it's done look I give it my
all it was just this that guy was just
better than me on that night yeah so for
sure you know I I get I get nervous but
I would like
I remember this is this is the thing
that I always do like I'm in the back
I'm just in my mind I'm in my head and
I'm just thinking like damn who your
next Max let's go and I start thinking
like what the like in my mind I think
what the frick am I doing we're here
again I told myself last time I was
gonna be here and then I'm and then I'm
going like [__] you can just work in
McDonald's or something either
easy life and then I think like [__] no
you can't do you can't do that [__] the
life you want to live costs money is
like yeah go out there and get yourself
get yourself out there son that's the
little prep talk I kind of talk to
myself I always like I I built I knock
myself down there I build myself up like
this time and then by the time we walk I
hear my song it's like it's go time
right so once you hear the song and
you're already walking you're in fight
mode oh yeah bro wants to walk out I
stay in the back of looking at my my
coaches smiling talking to him and
telling them brother it's another one
and then they'll tell me all right let's
go how do you feel like Bruce is calling
your name now bro I I'm just stoked bro
I in my mind now I'm like Bruce hurry
hurry up like wrap this up bro I just
wanna [__] I gotta do all the sponsors
and stuff Spiderman yeah come on bro
yeah yeah yeah he's like yeah
what's that about yeah exactly exactly
so nowadays it's like come on Bruce bro
let me let me punch this guy in the face
let me bang what's the song what's the
song you always come out to I walk up to
uh I do an Ed and then I always end it
with Hawaiian kickboxer yeah there's a
there's a guy from uh from Waianae he
made the song monkey boy his name is
called monkey boy and uh it was funny
because his dad is actually my uh he's
the his dad was the janitor at the at
the elementary
yeah pretty cool so then we have home
ties and yeah he's from Martin I'm I'm
friends with the with the guy who sings
the song so it's great he keeps like
telling me I want to change the song Max
I want to change the song I want to make
it a little bit more more popular more
hip-hoppy I was like freaking noise I'm
not going to walk her toy I was like
please do not change this song
the song I Want You Know